This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the early 2000s, an architect named Tray Jordan wrote a letter to Santa Fe, New Mexico's Historic Preservation Division, laying out the details of a house he was hoping to build in the city's historic district. The process started out pretty normal. We were just not ready for what happened. I mean, I don't remember the process being that thorny. The first indication that things maybe wouldn't go smoothly had to do with the color of the stucco that Tray wanted to use. I do recall that in my proposal letter, I had mentioned that the stucco color would be a custom color similar to, I think it was cotton wood, which is its standard color of a commercially available stucco.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。早在 2000 年代初期，一位名叫特雷·乔丹的建筑师给新墨西哥州圣达菲的历史保护处写了一封信，详细说明了他希望在该市历史街区建造房屋的构想。整个过程一开始还算挺正常的。我们只是对接下来发生的事情毫无准备。我的意思是，我不记得这个过程有那么棘手。事情可能不会顺利的第一个征兆，与特雷想要使用的灰泥颜色有关。我确实记得在我的提案信中，我提到过灰泥的颜色将是一种定制颜色，类似于，我想是棉木色，这是市面上可以买到的某种灰泥的标准颜色。
Buildings in the historic district have to follow a number of design guidelines so that they fit in with Santa Fe's traditional Adobe look. Senior producer Delaney Hall The style, called Pueblo Revival, comes from indigenous Pueblo architecture and the areas old Spanish missions. Think low-brown buildings with smooth edges. In the historic district, buildings can only be so tall, windows have to be a certain distance from the corners, roofs generally have to be flat, and stuccoes have to be earth-tone.
历史街区的建筑物必须遵循许多设计准则，以便与圣达菲传统的阿多比风格相融合。高级制作人德兰妮·霍尔 这种被称为普韦布洛复兴的风格，源自土著普韦布洛建筑和该地区古老的西班牙传教士建筑。想象一下边缘光滑的低矮棕色建筑物。在历史街区，建筑物的高度是有限制的，窗户必须距离墙角有一定的距离，屋顶通常必须是平的，灰泥也必须是大地色系。
And the stucco tray wanted to use the color that was close to cottonwood. It was an earth tone. It was just a little different than usual. Still, the board approved it. But then things started to get weird. When we stuccoed the house, it got back to me that two of the board members were very upset about the color, and they took samples of cottonwood over to the house to hold it up to the steka. Well, of course, it didn't match cottonwood, but as I said in my letter, it would be a custom color similar to, and I think it was quite obvious that it was.
而特雷想要使用的灰泥颜色接近棉木色。它是一种大地色。只是比平时稍微不同了一点。尽管如此，委员会还是批准了它。但随后事情开始变得诡异起来。当我们给房子刷上灰泥后，我听说其中两名委员会成员对颜色非常不满，他们拿着棉木色的样本到房子那里，把它比着灰泥对照。好吧，它当然和棉木色不匹配，但正如我在信中所说，它将是一种类似于……的定制颜色，而且我认为这很明显就是那样。
There were other subtle ways that the house was different from the traditional Santa Fe look. The corners, for instance. So the corners were sharp, not round, not the Ouy-Guy, Pueblo Revival look, but a little more crisp than that geometric. I've seen this house, and it's a bit modern, a bit angular, but honestly, it is not wildly different from the surrounding homes, which are done in a more traditional style.
这座房子在其他微妙的方面也不同于传统的圣达菲风格。例如，墙角。因此，墙角是尖锐的，而不是圆的，不是那种典型的普韦布洛复兴风格，而是比几何图形更 crisp（利落）一点。我见过这栋房子，它有点现代，有点棱角分明，但老实说，它与周围采用更传统风格建造的房屋并没有太大的不同。
And even with the bumps in the process, like the disagreement about the stucco, Tray just wasn't expecting what happened next. A few weeks after his clients had moved in, Tray got a call from them. The house had been defaced in the middle of the night. You know, it was really, really frightening and really, really shocking that someone would get so angry that they would terrorize another family by defacing their house with the Shwastika and writing the words Nazi architecture on it. Nazi architecture had been painted on the side of the house.
尽管过程中遇到了波折，比如对灰泥颜色的分歧，但特雷完全没有料到接下来会发生什么。在他的客户搬进去几周后，特雷接到了他们的电话。房子在半夜被人恶意涂画毁容了。你知道，这真的、真的很可怕，也真的、真的很让人震惊，竟然有人会愤怒到通过在别人的房子上画上卐字标志并写上“纳粹建筑”这样的字眼来恐怖化另一家人。“纳粹建筑”几个字被喷漆写在了房子的侧面。
They don't know who did it. I was so just completely shocked and frankly scared. I was really, I just thought, what is going on? Why do you think they wrote Nazi architecture? You know, I don't know if they just felt it was too strong or too modern. We think it was a comment about wanting to stop buildings like this from happening in the historic districts. If you're not from Santa Fe, this whole incident probably strikes you as totally absurd. And to be fair, even people from Santa Fe marveled at this when it went down. You know, there was some period of time thereafter where people would want to drive by and see it,
他们不知道是谁干的。我当时简直震惊极了，坦白说也很害怕。我真的……我当时就在想，这到底是怎么回事？你觉得他们为什么会写“纳粹建筑”？你知道，我不知道他们是不是觉得这太强烈或太现代了。我们认为这是一个关于希望阻止这类建筑在历史街区出现的评论。如果你不是圣达菲本地人，整个事件可能让你觉得极其荒谬。平心而论，当这件事发生时，就连圣达菲本地人都感到大为惊奇。你知道，在那之后的有一段时间里，人们会想要开车路过并看上一眼，
because of course it became, in this unfortunate way, it became notable. And it was so funny, because so many people would call me and they'd just say, I don't understand what the problem is here. I just don't see it. I don't get it. I love the Pueblo Revival style. It's part of what gives Santa Fe its very distinctive look.
因为这当然以这种不幸的方式变得引人注目了。这太搞笑了，因为有那么多人打电话给我，他们只是说，我不明白这里有什么问题。我就是看不出来。我不明白。我喜欢普韦布洛复兴风格。这是赋予圣达菲独特外观的一部分。
It looks like no other city in the US, like no other city in the world. And people here are proud of that. But for some in the city, historic preservation is a very serious business. The aesthetics of Santa Fe have been carefully crafted and preserved. And deviating from those aesthetics is seen at least by some as a serious events. You know, and I'm going to call you a Nazi level of events. And this battle over style goes back more than 100 years.
它看起来不像美国任何其他城市，不像世界上任何其他城市。这里的人们为此感到自豪。但对这座城里的某些人来说，历史保护是一件非常严肃的事情。圣达菲的美学是经过精心塑造和保护的。而偏离这种美学，至少在某些人看来是一件非常严重的事情。你知道的，我称之为纳粹级别的事件。这场关于风格的争斗可以追溯到 100 多年前。
Ever since a group of early preservationists set out a vision for Santa Fe's architecture, and in the process dramatically transformed the town. Adobe has a long history in Northern New Mexico, building with mud goes back hundreds and hundreds of years. The technique was favored both by the indigenous people of the region and by the Spanish settlers who arrived later on. But back in the 1800s, when New Mexico was vying to become a state, Santa Fe actually tried to leave its mud-based architecture behind. The city constructed buildings that screamed, hey, we're just like you guys. They were Italian-ate business blocks on the plaza.
自从一群早期的保护主义者为圣达菲的建筑勾勒出愿景，并在这一过程中戏剧性地改造了这座城镇以来。阿多比（生土砖）在新墨西哥州有着悠久的历史，用泥土建造房屋可以追溯到几百年前。这种技术既受到该地区土著人民的青睐，也受到后来到达的西班牙定居者的喜爱。但在 19 世纪，当新墨西哥州争取成为一个州时，圣达菲实际上试图抛弃其基于泥土的建筑。这座城市建造了那些大喊着“嘿，我们跟你们一样”的建筑。它们是广场上的意大利风格商业街区。
Architectural historian Chris Wilson. Schools and kind of a red brick Romanesque style on 1900 neoclassical capital that would Chris Wilson. The local leaders hoped this architectural posturing would help convince Congress to let New Mexico into the Union. They were well aware that East Coasters viewed them with some suspicion. The territory seemed like a dusty foreign outpost, unlikely to integrate into mainstream American culture. Eventually, in 1912, after more than 60 years of trying, New Mexico became a state.
建筑历史学家克里斯·威尔逊。学校以及一种红砖罗曼式风格，1900 年代的新古典主义国会大厦，克里斯·威尔逊说。当地领导人希望这种建筑姿态能帮助说服国会允许新墨西哥州加入联邦。他们非常清楚，东海岸的人对他们抱有一定的怀疑态度。这片领土看起来像是一个尘土飞扬的外国前哨基地，不太可能融入主流美国文化。最终，在 1912 年，经过 60 多年的努力，新墨西哥州成为了一个州。
But all of these attempts to fit in, they ended up being a bad thing, especially for New Mexico's newly minted capital, Santa Fe. Santa Fe was struggling economically. There was a railroad that went through New Mexico, but despite being called the Santa Fe Railroad, it didn't go directly through Santa Fe, and the city couldn't develop any serious industries without good rail access. Santa Fe was rapidly shrinking, and so the mayor at the time put together a planning board and told them to come up with a plan to save the city.
但是所有这些融入主流的尝试，最终都成了一件坏事，特别是对新墨西哥州刚刚诞生的首府圣达菲而言。圣达菲在经济上苦苦挣扎。有一条铁路线穿过新墨西哥州，但尽管名为圣达菲铁路，它并没有直接穿过圣达菲，如果没有良好的铁路交通，这座城市就无法发展任何严肃的产业。圣达菲在迅速萎缩，于是当时的市长组建了一个规划委员会，让他们想出一个拯救城市的计划。
They landed on tourism. Tourists had already started to come to Santa Fe in small numbers, but the board noticed that when they arrived, they weren't that impressed. Once they see our Americanized city, they press on, they press north to the Pueblos. Tourism can be our salvation, but only if we reverse the ill-conceived Americanization of the last three decades. The board wrote up a document that's become known as the 1912 Plan. I recommended the city preserve its traditional Adobe architecture, but the plan went even further. It said that any new development should also be done in the Santa
他们看中了旅游业。游客已经开始少量来到圣达菲，但委员会注意到，当他们到达时，并没有留下多么深刻的印象。一旦他们看到我们美国化了的城市，他们就会继续前进，向北前往普韦布洛。旅游业可以成为我们的救赎，但前提是我们必须扭转过去三十年里那些构思拙劣的美国化进程。委员会起草了一份被称为《1912年计划》的文件。我建议该市保护其传统的阿多比建筑，但该计划走得更远。它表示，任何新的开发项目也应该以圣达菲风格建造。
Phase style. They wanted to create a kind of city-wide architectural brand based on the historical precedent. The sweeping scope of the 1912 plan was pretty radical. At the time, most historic preservation in the US focused on the homes of important old-white guys. Mount Vernon, Monticello, so preservation was focused on single buildings. Santa Fe, on the other hand, decided to focus on the everyday architecture of its ordinary people, and it expanded preservation beyond single buildings to the entire community. A city had never tried something so far-reaching. But many of the leaders behind the effort believed that this could be Santa Fe's salvation, not in pretending to be a conventional American city, but in embracing its difference and selling it
他们希望根据历史先例创造一种全市范围的建筑品牌。《1912年计划》的宏大范围相当激进。在当时，美国的大多数历史保护都集中在重要老白男的住宅上。弗农山庄、蒙蒂塞洛，因此保护工作集中在单一建筑物上。另一方面，圣达菲决定专注于其普通百姓的日常建筑，并将保护范围从单栋建筑扩大到整个社区。一个城市从未尝试过如此深远的事情。但这一努力背后的许多领导人相信，这可能是圣达菲的救赎，不是通过假装成一个传统的美国城市，而是通过拥抱自己的差异并将其兜售给局外人。
to outsiders. To those who are devotees of the great outdoors, to the splendors of its vastness and magnificent scenery, the urge is west to the Indian country. Santa Fe's tourism campaign took off. By the 19 teens, a wave of mostly white newcomers began arriving in the state. They were artists and anthropologists and health seekers. Chris Wilson calls them internal expats. The kind of people who might have gone to Paris, but instead went to Santa Fe.
对于那些热爱户外活动、向往广阔天地和壮丽风景的人来说，他们的冲动是向西进入印第安乡村。圣达菲的旅游宣传活动蓬勃发展。到 20 世纪 10 年代，一股主要由白人新来者组成的浪潮开始涌入该州。他们是艺术家、人类学家和寻求健康的人。克里斯·威尔逊称他们为内部侨民。那种可能去了巴黎，但最终却来到了圣达菲的人。
And one of those newcomers was John Gawmeam. I became particularly aware of the New Mexican architecture while lying in bed. John Gawmeam was a civil engineer who'd come to Santa Fe from New York to recover from tuberculosis. And while he was recuperating, he became enthralled with the architecture. And I decided in and there, even though I was, I thought getting very advanced in years, I'd better change my profession and what I really wanted to be was an architect. And so at the very advanced age of 27, meme switched careers and quickly became Santa Fe's go-to architect, especially for wealthy transplants from the East Coast in Midwest.
这些新来者中就包括约翰·高梅姆。我躺在床上时，对新墨西哥州的建筑产生了特别的认识。约翰·高梅姆是一位土木工程师，他为了从肺结核中康复，从纽约来到了圣达菲。在疗养期间，他被这里的建筑迷住了。我当机立断，尽管当时我认为自己已经上了年纪，但我最好还是改变我的职业，而我真正想成为的是一名建筑师。因此，在 27 岁这个“高龄”，梅姆转行了，并迅速成为圣达菲最抢手的建筑师，特别是为来自东海岸和中西部地区富裕的迁居者服务。
But also then of important public buildings, churches, county courthouse, and so forth. also then of important public buildings, churches, county court houses and so forth. Meme became the leading architect of the Santa Fe style, and he helped to bring a very old building tradition into the modern era. He didn't always use actual mud bricks. He used reinforced concrete and steel to create an adobe-ish take on that old style. And his work helped the city of Santa Fe actually create the architectural brand it had imagined. And I think it's perfect in legitimate, not only legitimate, but almost a duty.
但也包括重要的公共建筑、教堂、县法院等等。梅姆成为了圣达菲风格的首席建筑师，他帮助将一个非常古老的建筑传统带入了现代。他并不总是使用真正的泥砖。他使用钢筋混凝土和钢材来创造一种带有该古老风格特征的阿多比风格建筑。他的作品帮助圣达菲市真正创造了它想象中的建筑品牌。我认为这是完美且正当的，不仅正当，而且几乎是一种责任。
In the part of the world where we have a native architecture with these wonderful shapes that we should recall them. It's worth was every. That's something I dreamed of doing 100% about Matt, as you know. All over town, new buildings went up in this Adobe style. And as far as attracting tourists, it worked. Between 1920 and 1930, Santa Fe went from 200 hotel rooms to 600.
在我们这个拥有具有这些奇妙形状的原生建筑的世界里，我们应该回想起它们。这是绝对值得的。马特，正如你所知，这正是我一直梦想做的事情。全城到处都建起了这种阿多比风格的新建筑。就吸引游客而言，它成功了。在 1920 年到 1930 年之间，圣达菲的酒店房间从 200 间增加到了 600 间。
Everything was going great until a pesky new form of architecture showed up on the scene threatening to ruin everything. In the 1950s, architectural modernism was spreading, even in Santa Fe. The city was growing, the tourist industry was driving more development, and there was a sense that Santa Fe was losing its grip on the style that had made it so distinct. And the traditionalist community that had reached this consensus around the revival style becomes alarmed
一切进展顺利，直到一种讨厌的新建筑形式出现在现场，威胁要毁掉这一切。20世纪50年代，建筑现代主义正在蔓延，甚至在圣达菲也是如此。城市在发展，旅游业推动了更多的开发，人们有一种感觉：圣达菲正在失去对其独特风格的掌控。而围绕复兴风格达成共识的传统主义社区开始感到惊慌，并对此做出反抗。
and they react against it. And so the preservationists with John Gaul meme as one of their leaders doubled down. In 1957, the city passed an ordinance that required the Santa Fe style. It elaborated a number of substiles and created a large historic district in the center of the city, which included some of Santa Fe's oldest neighborhoods. They were full of Hispanic families.
因此，以约翰·高梅姆为领导者之一的保护主义者加倍投入。1957 年，该市通过了一项法令，强制推行圣达菲风格。它详细阐述了许多子风格，并在市中心创建了一个大型历史街区，其中包括圣达菲一些最古老的街区。那里住满了西班牙裔家庭。
Some of them had lived for generations in Adobe Homes built by their ancestors. With this new ordinance, any changes to a building in the district now had to be approved by a design board. And at first, critics worried mostly about aesthetics. They thought the look of the city would become boring and homogenous, or that it would turn into a kind of hokey, old west stage set. They weren't against the city having a distinctive character,
他们中有些人已经在祖先建造的阿多比房屋中生活了好几代。有了这项新法令，该街区建筑的任何改动现在都必须获得设计委员会的批准。起初，批评者主要担心美学问题。他们认为城市的外观会变得单调和同质化，或者它会变成一种俗气的旧西部片场布景。他们并不反对这座城市拥有独特的个性，
but they just doubted that the style guidelines were going to do it in the most vibrant living way. And were there questions raised about what the ordinance might do to affordability in the central city? No, there weren't arguments about, you know, potential gentrification, as we would call it now. Finally tonight, the sound of moving that roar you hear in the American Southwest these days is the traffic heading to Santa Fe, New Mexico. The population is up 12% over the past decade. Over the next couple decades, Santa Fe got hit with a huge wave of tourism and resettlement.
但他们只是怀疑这些风格准则是否能以最具活力、最生动的方式做到这一点。是否有人对该法令可能对市中心负担能力产生的影响提出质疑？不，当时并没有关于我们现在所称的潜在优越化（gentrification）的争论。最后今晚，搬迁的声音，你现在在美国西南部听到的轰鸣声是前往新墨西哥州圣达菲的交通流。过去十年人口增长了 12%。在接下来的几十年里，圣达菲受到了旅游业和重新定居潮的巨大冲击。
In the 1970s, there was an oil boom in neighboring Texas, and a bunch of newly-rich Texans moved to Santa Fe. Then, in the 1980s, as international travel became more of a thing, Santa Fe became not just a national destination, but an international one. The city had spent decades perfecting its tourist identity, figuring out how to package and sell itself. Maybe two effectively. The readers of CondiNess, Travel magazine in the early 1980s, but Santa Fe, their number one tourist destination,
在 20 世纪 70 年代，邻近的德克萨斯州发生了石油繁荣，一群暴富的德州人搬到了圣达菲。然后，在 20 世纪 80 年代，随着国际旅行变得越来越普遍，圣达菲不仅成为一个国内旅游目的地，还成为了一个国际旅游目的地。这座城市花了数十年时间来完善其旅游身份，摸索如何包装和销售自己。也许太有效了。20 世纪 80 年代初《悦游》（Condé Nast Traveler）杂志的读者，将圣达菲评为他们的头号旅游目的地，
and not just in the United States, but in the world. A million, sometimes two million tourists started coming every year. This was in a town of 50 or 60,000 residents. Santa Fe started to get totally overrun by these visitors. And some of these visitors decided to buy up more of the city's old historic homes. This was gentrification, but like, on steroids. These are the one percent or the one tenth of one percent, the very wealthiest of people who start to have multiple homes.
不仅在美国，而且在全世界。每年有一百万，有时甚至两百万游客开始涌入。这是一个只有五六万居民的小镇。圣达菲开始完全被这些游客淹没。其中一些游客决定买下更多这座城市的老历史住宅。这是士绅化，但就像打了鸡血一样。这些人是百分之一或千分之一的人，也就是最富有的那些开始拥有多处房产的人。
They have a Pietatera in Manhattan and they've got a house in Antarctica and maybe a Pietatera in Paris and now they want to have a house in Santa Fe. In Santa Fe the neighborhoods are changing as fast as the builders can put up new buildings. There aren't a lot of barrios left, they're all becoming playgrounds for the rich. For the first time since 1600 there are now more anglos here than there are Hispanics. It was during the 90s that Tray Jordan, the architect, started working for an architecture firm in Santa Fe, and he loved learning to build in the Santa Fe style. It's a vernacular that I think a lot of people find it easy to like. I mean, there's something
他们在曼哈顿有一个小公寓（Pied-à-terre），在南极洲有一栋房子，在巴黎可能还有一个小公寓，现在他们想在圣达菲也有一栋房子。在圣达菲，社区改变的速度和建筑工人建造新建筑的速度一样快。没有留下多少贫民区了，它们都在变成富人的游乐场。自 1600 年以来，这里的盎格鲁撒克逊人数量首次超过了西班牙裔。正是在 90 年代，建筑师特雷·杰丹开始在圣达菲的一家建筑事务所工作，他非常喜欢学习用圣达菲风格建造房屋。这是一种我认为很多人都会觉得很容易喜欢的本土建筑风格。我的意思是，它有一种相当迷人的地方。
quite charming about it. But he could also understand the irony of what was happening. How this old tradition had become invogue with Santa Fe's wealthy newcomers. It's more or less a vernacular of poverty and a vernacular of survival. And we spend extraordinary amounts of money to nowadays reproduce a style that was really, you know, born out of necessity. Over time, the city implemented more restrictions and more code. The historic districts expanded. Limits were placed on the height of buildings. Commercial districts were encouraged to adopt the Adobe look. And so Santa Fe began to have stuff like a fake Adobe iHop and a fake Adobe Panda Express. A wave of brown stucco washed over the city. The 80s and 90s were a tough time for a
但他也理解正在发生的事情所具有的讽刺意味。这种古老的传统是如何在圣达菲富裕的新来者中变得流行的。这或多或少是一种贫穷的本土风格，一种生存的本土风格。而我们今天却花费巨资来复制一种实际上由于需要而诞生的风格。随着时间的推移，这座城市实施了更多的限制和更多的法规。历史街区扩大了。对建筑物的高度进行了限制。商业街区被鼓励采用阿多比外观。因此，圣达菲开始出现诸如山寨阿多比风格的国际ハウス（IHOP）和山寨阿多比风格的熊猫快餐之类的东西。一股棕色灰泥的浪潮席卷了这座城市。对圣达菲的许多人来说，80 年代和 90 年代是一段艰难的时期。
lot of people in Santa Fe. I asked one old timer, Joseph Montoya, what it was like living here during those years, and he thought for a couple moments before saying, it sucked. I think what happened, whether it's appropriate or not, a building resentment over like, gosh, we've got a lot of fine restaurants now in town that we didn't have before, right? I can't eat in them. Joseph's family connection to Santa Fe goes back generations. Oh, I don't go to the plaza because it's no longer my plaza. I don't feel comfortable in my own town. Joseph joined the city government in 1990. He's now the executive director of the county housing authority. Back then, he was also working on community development and housing issues.
我问了一位老居民约瑟夫·蒙托亚，在那几年里这里生活是怎样的，他思考了一会儿然后说：“糟透了。”我想发生的事情是，无论是否合适，人们对诸如“天哪，我们现在城里有很多以前没有的好餐馆”之类的现象积聚了一种怨恨，对吧？我吃不起。约瑟夫家族与圣达菲的渊源可以追溯到好几代人。哦，我不去广场，因为那不再是我的广场。我在我自己的城镇里感到不舒服。约瑟夫于 1990 年加入市政府。他现在是县住房管理局的执行主任。当时，他也从事社区发展和住房问题的工作。
authority. Back then, he was also working on community development and housing issues. And the first thing he did was review some studies the city had already done, trying to understand why locals couldn't afford to live here anymore. He says that there was even one study that tried to actually quantify the cost of the Santa Phase style, like the exposed wood beams that support the ceilings in many homes. How much de do they cost? Is there a cost difference between the kind of windows you have to put in or not or different doors? And they tried to add up that cost over and above what you might have to pay anyway. And yeah, the car of wood beams and the ornamental corbling, for example, did add some costs.
管理局。当时，他也在从事社区发展和住房问题的工作。他做的第一件事就是审查该市已经做过的一些研究，试图了解为什么当地人再也买不起这里的房子了。他说，甚至有一项研究试图真正量化圣达菲风格的成本，比如许多房屋中支撑天花板的裸露木梁。它们的成本是多少？你必须安装的窗户种类与否或不同的门之间是否存在成本差异？他们试图将超出你无论如何都必须支付的成本之外的费用加起来。是的，例如木梁和装饰性托梁确实增加了一些成本。
But that wasn't really the central issue. More relevant was the number of wealthy buyers flooding the city and driving up the cost of everything, including land. The city just couldn't build enough subsidized housing to keep lower income people housed. And that was partly because some of those newcomers began to fight new construction. Not just in the historic district, but across the city. Joseph talks about the arguments they would make at community meetings. They
但那并不是核心问题。更相关的是涌入该市并推高一切成本（包括土地成本）的富有买家的数量。这座城市根本无法建造足够的补贴住房来让低收入人群有房可住。部分原因是其中一些新来者开始反对新建筑。不仅在历史街区，而且在整个城市。约瑟夫谈到了他们在社区会议上提出的论点。他们
would speak out against more density, more infill housing, taller buildings. They would say, this is going to ruin the quality of my life. I bought here expecting it to always stay the same because the community character is important to me. And it was seen as you were being a good citizen, right? And, you know, I think that's something that worked for a lot of people, right? That, oh yeah, development is what ruined this city, and now we're going to stop it. But all they talk about community character always frustrated Joseph. Because what community were they talking about? And what character?
会大声反对更多的密度、更多的填充式住宅、更高的建筑物。他们会说，这将毁了我的生活质量。我买这里的房子是期望它永远保持不变，因为社区特色对我很重要。这被视为你是一个好公民，对吧？而且，你知道，我认为这对很多人来说是管用的，对吧？哦，是的，发展是毁了这座城市的元凶，现在我们要阻止它。但他们谈论社区特色总是让约瑟夫感到沮丧。因为他们在谈论哪个社区？什么特色？
So it was like, my God, you know, I know exactly that place are talking about. We used to hunt rabbits there. And so that was the community character back then. And previous to that, that was a Native American cap ground. So what character were you taking? You know, the character that was created in 1973. Joseph watched in dismay as the Nimbis gained political power
所以就像是，天哪，我知道他们说的是哪个地方。我们以前在那里抓兔子。所以那是当时的社区特色。在此之前，那是美洲原住民的露营地。那么你在承袭什么特色呢？你知道，那个在 1973 年创造的特色。约瑟夫沮丧地看着邻避主义者（NIMBYs）获得政治权力和影响力。
and influence. I felt that if we've gotten to the point where there's a majority of people that the politicians were listening to, they can make this arguments and win. The city has been lost. It was sad to see the demise, the complete demise of families and history and legacy being washed away. In some ways, Santa Fe had become a victim of its own success.
我觉得，如果我们已经到了政客们倾听的大多数人能够提出这些论点并获胜的地步，这座城市就已经迷失了。看到家庭、历史和传统被完全冲刷殆尽的消亡，令人感到悲伤。在某些方面，圣达菲已经成了自身成功的受害者。
The early preservationists set out a vision for protecting Santa Fe's historic look, and they helped create a tourism industry that's still the foundation of the city's economy. But the popularity of Santa Fe has also helped to create serious inequality. The town became an increasingly expensive place to live, and lots of people work in hospitality, taking care of tourists and making service economy wages. Locals who were pushed out of the historic district moved to the more affordable south side. Now many of them can't even afford to live there.
早期的保护主义者制定了保护圣达菲历史风貌的愿景，他们帮助打造了一个至今仍是城市经济基石的旅游业。但圣达菲的受欢迎程度也加剧了严重的社会不平等。这座城镇成为一个生活成本日益高昂的地方，许多人在酒店业工作，照顾游客并拿着服务经济的工资。被挤出历史街区的当地人搬到了更加负担得起的南部。现在，他们中的许多人甚至连那里都住不起了。
Of the 80 cousins Joseph grew up with, he says only five are still in the city. These days, more than half of the people who work in Santa Fe don't live here, including Joseph. He lives in Albuquerque, commuting from an hour away to fight for affordable housing in his old hometown. Up until recently, I lived on the historic east side of Santa Fe in a blocky and frankly, unattractive yellow stucco house surrounded by gorgeous multi-million dollar Adobe homes. And it
在约瑟夫一起长大的 80 个表亲中，他说只有 5 个还留在城里。如今，在圣达菲工作的人中有一半以上不住在这里，包括约瑟夫在内。他住在阿尔伯克基，每天通勤一小时，回到他的老家为经济适用房而战。直到最近，我一直住在圣达菲历史悠久的东区，住在一栋块状且坦率地说并不吸引人的黄色灰泥房子里，周围是华丽的价值数百万美元的阿多比住宅。这是一个奇怪的居住地方。
was a strange place to live. I would sometimes find myself walking through the neighborhood as evening approached and the sky got dark. And I was always struck by the number of homes in which the lights just never came on. The neighborhood was eerily quiet. Down the street from me, there was an old adobe house that no one seemed to live in. There was never a car in the driveway. I literally never saw someone come or go. But landscapers would come in a couple times a month to mow the lawn and trim the trees.
有时我会在傍晚临近、天空变黑时发现自己正走过这个社区。我总是对许多房屋里灯光从不亮起这一现象感到震惊。这个街区出奇的安静。在我这条街的尽头，有一栋似乎没有人住的老阿多比房子。车道上从来没有过汽车。我真的从来没见过有人进出。但园林绿工一个月会来几次来修剪草坪和树枝。
It was a beautifully maintained, seemingly empty specimen. We have been very intent on preserving the architectural character of our historic districts, but what has fallen through the cracks has been the community character and how that has really changed. This is Lisa Gabioli Roach. She first worked in the historic preservation division as a senior planner, and she said it often felt like they managed the districts as if the buildings were works of art in a museum.
这是一个维护精美、看似空无一人的样板。我们一直非常致力于保护我们历史街区的建筑特色，但被忽视的却是社区特色以及它究竟发生了怎样的变化。这就是莉萨·加比奥利·罗奇（Lisa Gabioli Roach）。她最初在历史保护处担任高级规划师，她说她经常觉得他们管理这些街区，就好像这些建筑物是博物馆里的艺术品一样。
There was little discussion, she said, of the people who actually lived in those neighborhoods. She started to question everything about her field, and then she became the head of the division, which put her in a position to try and about her field. And then she became the head of the division, which put her in a position to try and make some changes. Now Lisa says it's a mistake for preservationists to focus exclusively on the built environment of a neighborhood. Neighborhoods aren't just a collection of buildings. It's not just visual character that you're looking at. It's the sounds that you hear, the smells that you smell, the people that you interact with, all of those things contribute to a community's character.
她说，几乎没有人讨论那些真正生活在这些街区里的人。她开始质疑她所在领域的方方面面，然后她成为了该部门的负责人，这使她处于能够尝试改变这一领域的地位。现在莉萨说，保护主义者只关注街区的建筑环境是一个错误。街区不仅仅是建筑物的集合。你看到的不仅仅是视觉特征。而是你听到的声音，你闻到的气味，你与之互动的 人，所有这些东西都构成了社区的特色。
And those things have been dramatically altered in the historic neighborhoods of Santa Faye over the past few decades. You don't often hear kids playing or see neighbors talking to each other over a fence. You're seeing tourists taking photos and you yourself start to feel like you're just like a character in a diorama or something. You know, it starts to feel very different. The transformation of Santa Fe's old neighborhoods is complex. It's not like historic preservation is entirely at fault, but Lisa does think it's played a role. The city's approach to preservation is highly prescriptive down to every single detail. Any exterior change has to come through our office and most of them need a permit, even if you're fixing your fence or repainting your windows or, you know, the little minor
在过去的几十年里，这些东西在圣达菲的历史街区发生了巨大的改变。你很少听到孩子们在玩耍，或者看到邻居在篱笆旁交谈。你看到的是游客在拍照，而你自己开始觉得自己就像立体模型中的一个角色或其他什么。你知道，感觉开始变得非常不同。圣达菲老街区的转变是复杂的。这并不是说历史保护要负全部责任，但莉萨确实认为它发挥了一定的作用。该市对保护的方法具有高度的规范性，甚至精确到每一个细节。任何外观上的改动都必须通过我们的办公室，而且大多数都需要许可证，即使你在修理篱笆、重新粉刷窗户，或者做一些类似的小事情。
things like that. It feels very invasive, I think, for many people. And the process is also expensive. It often requires hiring an architect. It's just one more thing that can make it hard for old-timers to stay in their homes. You know, I was speaking to a homeowner just last week who was talking to me about her experience,
我认为，对许多人来说，这感觉非常具有侵入性。而且这个过程也很昂贵。它通常需要聘请建筑师。这只是又一个让老住户难以留在自己家里的因素。你知道，就在上周我还和一位房主交谈，她跟我谈起了她翻修祖父房子的经历。
renovating her grandfather's home. And she just said the whole time that she was going through it, she really felt like it was tearing her family apart and she just wondered what are we preserving. She just kept saying that what are we preserving because certainly my family's not being preserved, my family's connection to this place is not being respected and it's so arduous just to get through it. Over the past eight months or so the Historic Division has been working on a study to quantify the changes that have happened in the city's historic districts over the years.
她只是说，在她经历这一切的整个过程中，她真的觉得这正在撕裂她的家庭，她只是在想我们在保护什么。她一直反复在问我们在保护什么，因为显然我的家庭没有得到保护，我的家族与这个地方的联系没有受到尊重，而且要度过这一关是如此的艰难。在过去的大约八个月里，历史保护处一直在进行一项研究，以量化多年来该市历史街区发生的变化。
They've found that between 1980 and 2018, even as the population of Santa Fe grew, the historic districts emptied out. Old families left, and their homes turned into second homes or short-term rentals. The people who now live in the historic district are generally white, wealthy, and old. The gentrification of our historic neighborhoods is all but complete, and in many ways it's not reversible. And I think instead of just singularly celebrating historic preservation for creating and maintaining this tourist economy, we have to recognize that there have been other experiences here as well,
他们发现，在 1980 年到 2018 年之间，尽管圣达菲的人口在增长，但历史街区却空心化了。老住户离开了，他们的家变成了第二居所或短期租赁房屋。现在住在历史街区的人通常是白人、富有且年迈。我们历史街区的士绅化几乎已经完成，而且在许多方面是不可逆转的。我认为，我们不能只是单纯地赞美历史保护创造和维持了这种旅游业经济，我们还必须认识到这里也经历过其他的事情，
and that the outcomes for our community are not all good. Is this really what we want? What do we value now in our community? It's not 1957 anymore, it's not 1912 anymore. There was one person I met while working on this story who embodied the complicated and sometimes contradictory relationship that Santa Fe has to its own past. Like Joseph, Ray Edetta's family has lived in Santa Fe for many generations. Ray grew up building and maintaining his family's old Adobe homes. Everybody built with Adobe back then. I guess you could say it's in your blood. If you're a local Hispanic like me, whose parents and grandparents and great grandparents were from Santa Fe, you know,
而且对我们社区的结果并非全都是好的。这真的是我们想要的吗？我们现在在社区中珍视什么？现在已经不是 1957 年了，也不是 1912 年了。在做这个报道时我遇到了一个人，他体现了圣达菲与其自身过去那种复杂且有时矛盾的关系。就像约瑟夫一样，雷·埃代塔（Ray Edetta）的家族在圣达菲已经生活了好几代人。雷是在建造和维护家族老阿多比房屋的环境中长大的。当时每个人都用阿多比建房。我想你可以说这流淌在你的血液里。如果你像我一样是当地的西班牙裔，你的父母、祖父母和曾祖父母原本都来自圣达菲，你知道的，
originally. Ray still lives in the historic district. His family is one of the few remaining so-called legacy families, and he's watched as many of his neighbors and friends have been forced to leave. But he still supports the work of historic preservation. In fact, he's extremely committed to it. I was there at every meeting for 20 some years.
最初是这样的。雷仍然住在历史街区。他的家族是为数不多的几户所谓的传承家族之一，他眼看着许多邻居和朋友被迫离开。但他仍然支持历史保护工作。事实上，他对此极其投入。我在二十年里参加了每一次会议。
Every week, Ray would show up at the H-Board meetings to it. I was there at every meeting for 20 some years. Every week, Ray would show up at the H-Board meetings to testify. He would remind new homeowners about the history of the neighborhood, about who used to live in their houses, and about what Santa Fe used to be like. The buildings speak for the people that were here a hundred years ago. Ray says his family and friends don't really understand his interest in preservation. For many of them, the historic districts and the whole project of preservation seems to be entirely in the interest of white homeowners. And my relatives and friends that don't live here anymore. They tell me, why do you spend your time fighting for the anglos?
每个星期，雷都会出现在历史保护委员会的会议上作证。他会提醒新房主关于街区的历史、谁曾住在他们的房子里，以及圣达菲过去是什么样子的。这些建筑在为一百年前这里的人民发声。雷说，他的亲戚和朋友并不真正理解他对保护的兴趣。对他们许多人来说，历史街区和整个保护项目似乎完全是为了白人房主的利益。而那些不再住在这里的亲戚和朋友对我说，你为什么要把时间花在为盎格鲁人争取利益上？
And I said, I'm not fighting for the anglos. I'm fighting to protect the small town feeling of sanity. That's what I try to preserve. You know, if we were up to these home builders and developers, we'd have homes running up and down the Sanafee River. And you don't think it's worth it, even if it's say, let Hispanic people who've been here for generations be here. The thing is that it's sort of too late to say that anymore because 90% of the Hispanic families have moved out.
我说，我不是在为盎格鲁人战斗。我是为了保护圣达菲的小镇风情而战。这就是我努力去保护的。你知道，如果由这些房屋建筑商和开发商说了算，我们的房屋就会沿着圣达菲河绵延不断。难道你不觉得这值得吗，即使这意味着让世世代代生活在这里的西班牙裔人留下来？问题在于，说这话已经有点太迟了，因为 90% 的西班牙裔家庭都已经搬走了。
It's almost as if unable to preserve the actual community of his neighborhood, the people he used to know, the neighbors he grew up with. Ray now has to be content to preserve the buildings they left behind. Over the years, Ray has fought every kind of development you can imagine. Development in the historic district, high-end housing developments, affordable housing developments. Anything greater than that was there fighting anything? If I showed up to a meeting, everybody stopped and looked and said, oh God, what's happening, Ray Reddaw is here.
就好像由于无法保护他街区真正的社区、他曾经认识的人、他一起长大的邻居，雷现在不得不满足于保护他们留下的建筑。多年来，雷与你能想象到的各种开发进行了抗争。历史街区的发展、高端住宅开发、经济适用房开发。任何比这更大的东西都在抗争吗？如果我出现在会议上，每个人都会停下来看着并说：“天哪，发生什么事了，雷·埃代塔来了。”
After watching Santa Fe change so much over his lifetime, Ray now resists every change he can. He's holding tight to an idea that many in Santa Fe believe deeply. It's a philosophy of urban planning that could be summed up as if we don't build it, they won't come. Well, if we don't build it, we're going to stay the same. And we want to stay the same. Joseph Montoya again. And that is simply not true, right? What happens is that the fittest survive, right? And people eventually get priced out of their ability to stay here.
在目睹了圣达菲在他的一生中发生了如此巨大的变化之后，雷现在竭尽全力抵制每一个他能抵制的变革。他紧紧抓住许多圣达菲人深信不疑的一个理念。这是一种城市规划哲学，可以概括为：如果我们不建设，他们就不会来。好吧，如果我们不建设，我们将保持原样。而我们希望保持原样。再次是约瑟夫·蒙托亚。而这根本不是真的，对吧？发生的事情是适者生存，对吧？人们最终因为付不起呆在这里的费用而被挤出去了。
Change is just a part of life. And so either accept it and try to take advantage of it or you try to deny it and you get run over by it. The early preservationists tried to freeze Santa Fe at a particular moment in time. The style that they defined in 1912 and then codified in 1957 largely remains the style of the city today. Yes, this had not been done.
变化只是生活的一部分。所以你要么接受它并试图利用它，要么你试图否认它然后被它碾压。早期的保护主义者试图将圣达菲冻结在某个特定的历史时刻。他们在 1912 年定义并在 1957 年法典化的风格在很大程度上仍然是当今该市的风格。是的，如果没有这样做。
We would have lost, I think, the kind to see that Santa Fe is right now. When John Gondonim said that, the city that Santa Fe is right now, it was 1964. He and the other preservationists couldn't have predicted the changes that would sweep over the city in the decades since then. But in holding on so tight to the architecture of that time, we've actually already lost a lot of the people and cultures that used to make Santa Fe what it was. And people like Joseph Montoya believe that if we don't change course, if we don't allow for more development and more housing,
我认为，我们会失去圣达菲现在所呈现的那种风貌。当约翰·戈东尼姆说这句话时，即圣达菲现在的样子，那是 1964 年。他和当年的其他保护主义者不可能预测到自那以后几十年里席卷这座城市的巨变。但在死死抓住那个时代的建筑不放的同时，我们其实已经失去了很多曾经造就圣达菲的人和文化。像约瑟夫·蒙托亚这样的人相信，如果我们不改变航向，如果我们不为更多的发展和更多的住房留出空间，
the rest of Santa Fe will follow suit. The whole city will become a kind of museum of cultures past, with only the buildings reflecting who once lived here. Coming up after the break, we'll learn more about the Pueblo building traditions that form the basis for the Santa Fe style. So we're back with Delaney again, and you have another story related to the Santa Fe style that you wanted to share with us. So where should we start? Well, I wanted to start with Roxanne Swensel. She's an artist and builder from Santa Clara Pueblo.
圣达菲的其他地方也将步其后尘。整个城市将变成某种过去文化的博物馆，只有建筑物在反映谁曾在这里生活过。广告休息回来后，我们将更多地了解构成圣达菲风格基础的普韦布洛建筑传统。我们又和德兰妮在一起了，你还有另一个关于圣达菲风格的故事想与我们分享。那么我们应该从哪里开始呢？嗯，我想从罗克珊·斯温塞尔（Roxanne Swentzell）开始。她是来自圣克拉拉普韦布洛的艺术家和建筑师。
And for people who aren't familiar with the Pueblos here in New Mexico, they're indigenous communities that, in some cases, go back for millennia. So they have a very long standing connection to this place. Very long. Yeah. And I would say in general, San Fe has a pretty complicated relationship with the surrounding Pueblos, you know, the city has built a tourism industry
对于不熟悉新墨西哥州普韦布洛人的人来说，他们是土著社区，在某些情况下可以追溯到几千年前。因此，他们与这个地方有着非常长久的联系。非常长久。是的。而且我想说，总的来说，圣达菲与周围的普韦布洛人有着相当复杂的关系，你知道，这座城市围绕着土著艺术和文化建立了一个旅游产业，
largely around indigenous art and culture and so architecture is just one example of that. And so when we talk about the Pueblo revival style, it's right there in the name. It's an interpretation or an appropriation of Pueblo design. And so I was curious to talk with Roxanne about what she makes of the architecture in Santa Fe. You know, there's a charming perspective. I can understand somebody coming in from somewhere else and thinking, this is different, this is kind of unique. For us that grew up here, I find it incredibly distasteful. And we joke, we call
而建筑只是其中的一个例子。所以当我们谈论普韦布洛复兴风格时，它就在名字里。它是对普韦布洛设计的诠释或挪用。因此，我很想和罗克珊谈谈她对圣达菲建筑的看法。你知道，有一种迷人的视角。我可以理解有人从别的地方来，然后觉得，这很不同，这有点独特。对于我们这些在这里长大的人来说，我发现这极其令人反感。我们开玩笑，我们把圣达菲叫作假圣达菲（Santa Fake），因为那些虚假的阿多比建筑。
Santa Fe Santa fake because of the fake Adobe. So there were a couple of reasons I wanted to speak with Roxanne. One is that she has a long history of building real Adobe houses. She's built 20 over the course of her life so far. And the other reason is that her mom, Reena Swenzel, wrote a lot about the disconnect between Pueblo ideas about architecture and European or I guess Western ideas about architecture.
所以我找罗克珊谈话有几个原因。一个是她有着建造真正的阿多比房屋的悠久历史。迄今为止，她在她的一生中建造了 20 栋。另一个原因是她的母亲丽娜·斯温塞尔（Rina Swentzell）写了很多关于普韦布洛建筑理念与欧洲或者说西方建筑理念之间脱节的文章。
And Rina died in 2015, but Roxanne told me about how she got interested in architecture in the first place. And it all went back to this conflict at the Pueblo in the 1970s. And what happened is that the government, HUD basically, came into Santa Clara to build new housing. But the houses had nothing to do with our cultural ways of life or values, but they were cheap
丽娜于 2015 年去世，但罗克珊向我讲述了她最初是如何对建筑产生兴趣的。这一切都可以追溯到 20 世纪 70 年代普韦布洛人的一场冲突。当时发生的事情是，政府，主要是美国住房和城市发展部（HUD），来到圣克拉拉建造新住房。但这些房子与我们的文化生活方式或价值观毫无关系，但它们很便宜而且是免费的。
and free. So, you know, people weren't going to turn that away, but my mother was desperate to see if she could stop it. And so, so why exactly did Rita want to stop it? The HUD houses were basically suburban in their design. You know, they were these single family homes. Where it's individual thinking, you have your own yard, you keep your neighbor out, you have your pre-fab house
所以，你知道，人们不会拒绝这个，但我母亲拼命想看看她是否能阻止它。那么，丽娜究竟为什么要阻止它呢？HUD 的房屋在设计上基本上是郊区的风格。你知道，它们是这些单户住宅。那是个人主义思维，你有自己的院子，你把邻居挡在外面，你拥有你的预制房屋
that you didn't make yourself. It's materials that you can't just go down the hill and dig up your mud and make a house. You have to have money to buy the materials the way the houses were designed. Had to do with a lifestyle that was foreign to poor blow lifestyle. And so Rina actually enrolled at the School of Architecture and Planning at UNM in Albuquerque. And Roxanne said that she really felt like she couldn't fight this new HUD development without first understanding the thinking behind it.
不是你自己造的。那些材料不是你随便下山去挖点泥巴就能盖个房子的。你得有钱买材料，而房屋的设计方式，与贫穷的普韦布洛人的生活方式格格不入。因此，丽娜实际上去了阿尔伯克基的UNM建筑与规划学院注册就读。罗珊说，她真的觉得自己如果不先弄懂HUD开发背后的思维方式，就无法与之抗争。
So she was very highly educated for that reason to really understand who these people were, how they thought, how they functioned, and her whole life was always trying to understand why they thought the way they did. So you have HUD who thinks they're solving a problem by providing free or subsidized housing, but they kind of have it all wrong, sort of based around individualism and suburbanism. And then you have that in conflict with the Pueblo worldview. Right, and Reena Swenzel really saw Pueblo architecture
所以她为此接受了非常高等的教育，以真正了解这些人是谁、他们是怎么想的、他们是如何运作的，她的一生都在试图理解他们为什么会那样思考。因此，HUD认为他们通过提供免费或补贴住房是在解决问题，但他们基本上都搞错了，这在某种程度上是围绕着个人主义和郊区化展开的。然后，这就与普韦布洛人的世界观产生了冲突。没错，丽娜·斯温泽确实将普韦布洛建筑
as an embodiment of the Pueblo worldview. She explained that you could understand a lot about Pueblo life by looking at its buildings and its village layout. The way the village was structured portrayed that kind of community thinking in that there would be the main central ceremonial house, the Kiva in the middle, with the outdoor spaces that everybody used and then these individual spaces for storage and sleeping that surrounded that. And then beyond that central space, Roxanne says there were buildings for more storage and
视为普韦布洛世界观的具体体现。她解释说，通过观察普韦布洛人的建筑和村庄布局，你可以对他们的生活了解很多。村庄的结构方式描绘了那种社群思维，即中间会有一个主要的中央礼仪大厅基瓦，周围是每个人都使用的户外空间，然后是环绕着这些空间的用于储藏和睡觉的个人空间。然后在这个中心空间之外，罗珊说还有更多的储藏建筑，以及
then there were the corrals and then beyond that there were the fields. There was always this feeling like you could go deeper into the circle or further out, but you always knew which was your circle and that was your village. So you could always find home. Home wasn't your individual house. It was the center of the village. So I think I know the answer to this, but were the HUD homes, you know, connected to this traditional structure at all? No, no, they basically weren't. They were built on the outskirts of the Pueblo, and they didn't have a connection to that central ceremonial place that Roxanne described. I can also imagine that the shift away from building
畜栏，再往外就是田地。总有一种感觉，你可以更深入到圆圈内部，或者去到更远的地方，但你总是知道哪个是你的圆圈，那就是你的村庄。所以你总是能找到家。家不是你个人的房子。它是村庄的中心。我想我知道答案，但是HUD的房屋，你知道的，和这种传统结构有任何联系吗？没有，完全没有。它们建在普韦布洛村庄的边缘，与罗珊所描述的那个中央礼仪场所没有任何联系。我也可以想象，从建造
your own home, instead of someone making it for you, really does change that perspective as well. Yeah, yeah, totally. And making homes was one of the ways that the Pueblo expressed its connection to this place, where they'd lived for hundreds and hundreds of years. So you know, you may watch a tree grow up from a little baby tree to a big tree,
你自己的房屋，转变为别人为你建造房屋，这种转变确实也改变了那种视角。是的，完全是这样。建造房屋是普韦布洛人表达他们与这片土地联系的方式之一，他们在这片土地上已经生活了成百上千年的时间。所以你知道，你可能会看着一棵树从小树苗长成一棵大树，
and then cut it down and use it in your house for a vika, but you know that tree. It's your family. The dirt you go get to plaster or make your adobies with and stuff, it's just right there. So you know where the good dirt is and where the not so good dirt is. It's it's absolutely having a relationship. And when a people stay in a place for many generations with that consciousness intact, the depth of the relationship becomes profound.
然后把它砍下来，用在你的房子里做房梁，但你了解那棵树。它是你的家人。你去取来抹墙或做土坯砖的泥土就在那儿。所以你知道哪里是好泥土，哪里不是那么好。这绝对是一种人与物之间的联系。当一个群体在一个地方生活了许多代，并且这种意识完好无损时，这种联系的深度就变得极其深厚。
And so is the houses then. Of course, they would be. Okay, so Roxanne's mom, Rina, she went to architecture school and began writing and developing all these ideas. She wrote about these ideas. You said that she opposed the HUD development. Did she end up really trying to fight the HUD development in Santa Clara? Yeah, she did. And Roxanne said that that part was really hard for her. She apparently talked with everyone she could talk with about it, but it was kind of an uphill battle. And Roxanne says, you know, there was a disagreement within the Pueblo itself about whether the
房子自然也是如此。当然会这样。好吧，所以罗珊的妈妈丽娜，她去了建筑学校，开始写作并发展所有这些想法。她写下了这些想法。你刚才说她反对HUD的开发项目？她最后真的试图在圣克拉拉抗击HUD的开发吗？是的，她确实这么做了。罗珊说那部分对她来说真的很艰难。她显然和所有能谈的人都谈过了，但这可以说是场硬仗。罗珊说，你知道的，普韦布洛人内部对于
HUD housing was a good thing or a bad thing. Lots of fights, lots of disagreements and stuff because there's a lot of people in the community that want to become mainstream and that's where they're going to go. That's okay. Everyone has to decide. But with my mother's help and others like her, there's this sense of like, let's really look at ourselves and see what is going on here so that we can choose. so that we can choose, because if we understand who we've been for thousands of years, and then within a very short time we're swept into pieces, wow, you know, this is enough to stop and really look at and think about, and start to really decide where we're going to go from here. That makes a tongue of sense. I mean, you can see totally the perspective of HUD trying to solve this problem.
HUD住房到底是好是坏其实存在分歧。有很多争吵，很多分歧之类的事情，因为社区里有很多人想要融入主流，那就是他们要走的路。这没关系。每个人都得自己做决定。但在我母亲和其他像她这样的人的帮助下，有一种感觉，那就是：让我们真正审视一下自己，看看这里到底发生了什么，这样我们才能做出选择。这样我们才能做出选择，因为如果我们了解自己几千年来是谁，然后在很短的时间内被粉碎成碎片，哇，你知道的，这足够让人停下来好好审视和思考，并开始真正决定我们从这里走向何方。
I mean, I grew up in HUD housing. Like I would be homeless if it wasn't for HUD, making sure that I had a home when I was a kid. But I wish they would have came into the situation with the same mindset that Reena did where she's like, I'm going to go to school and understand all of this. They really didn't come in with that mindset, that's for sure. That's true, that is true. And I think in the case of the Pueblos,
这太有道理了。我的意思是，你完全可以看出HUD试图解决这个问题的角度。我的意思是，我就是在HUD住房里长大的。如果不是HUD确保我在小时候有个家，我可能就无家可归了。但我希望他们进入这种情境时能带着和丽娜一样的心态，当时她心想：我要去学校把这一切都弄明白。他们来的时候可真没带着那种心态，这是肯定的。确实如此，确实如此。而且我认为对于普韦布洛人来说，
it's a very particular context. So these are places and people that have experienced multiple waves of conquest and settlement, and they've really had to fight to keep their traditions alive. And so I think Farina, this felt like one more way that changes were being forced onto the community. I remember my mother being very troubled because it was just one more way the government
这是一个非常特殊的环境。所以这些地方和人民经历过多次征服和定居的浪潮，他们真的不得不奋斗来保持传统的延续。因此我认为对丽娜来说，这感觉像是又一种将变革强加给社区的方式。我记得我母亲非常烦恼，因为这只是政府将我们同化进美国社会的又一种方式。
was assimulating us into the American society. But of course, you know, to your point about the importance of affordable housing, yeah, that situation is complicated. Like, in Santa Fe, there can be this obsession with traditional historic styles at the expense of just building out more affordable housing. But then, in this Santa Clara example, out more affordable housing. But then in this Santa Claire example, there was affordable housing coming in that just didn't do enough to acknowledge traditional styles and practices when it comes to housing. Yeah, there's just gotta be this balance between building affordable housing and being sensitive to the local context, like
当然，你知道的，就你刚才提到的经济适用房的重要性而言，是的，情况很复杂。比如在圣菲，人们可能会痴迷于传统的历史风格，而牺牲了建造更多经济适用房的机会。但在圣克拉拉这个例子中，经济适用房进驻了，但它们在涉及住房时，却没有做足够的工作来承认传统风格和做法。是的，在建造经济适用房和对本地环境保持敏感之间，必须找到一个平衡点，就像在
all everywhere. Right. And you know, it was interesting. There were affordable housing advocates. I spoke to while I was researching this story who said, you know, in Santa Fe, if we're interested in building a community that is rooted in historical building practices, the public do have a lot to teach us. So there are some traditional public communities, for example, that are four or five stories tall, they're dense, they're multi-unit,
所有地方一样。没错。而且你知道，这很有趣。我在研究这个故事时采访了一些经济适用房倡导者，他们说，你知道，在圣菲，如果我们有兴趣建立一个植根于历史建筑实践的社区，普韦布洛人确实有很多东西可以教给我们。例如，有些传统的普韦布洛社区有四五层楼高，它们很密集，是多单元的，
and that kind of building is rare in Santa Fe, which is mostly built around the single family, single story model. Wow, so basically, the style the style of public architecture that Santa Fe sort of grabbed onto in the historic preservation was just this one really narrow slice of Adobe architecture, but there's so much more to learn from that they could be doing and creating dense housing. Yeah, yeah definitely. So in the case of Santa Clara, did they eventually choose to include the HUD housing in their community?
而这种建筑在圣菲很少见，圣菲主要还是围绕着单户、单层的模式建造的。哇，所以基本上，圣菲在历史保护中抓住的那种普韦布洛建筑风格，仅仅是土坯建筑中非常狭窄的一个切片，但实际上还有很多东西可以向他们学习，并且他们本可以借此建造和创造密集的住房。是的，是的，绝对是这样。所以在圣克拉拉的案例中，他们最终选择将HUD住房纳入他们的社区了吗？
Yes, they did. And how did it affect the public? What does it like these days? Yeah, I asked Roxanne about that. And she said the center of the village still has its old Adobe buildings. But the middle of the village has emptied out of a lot of people. It's kind of like a ghost town of sorts, and it only gets filled up on feast days or certain occasions. There's a few houses that have people in, but most of the people have moved out to the suburbs. So it broke, it fragmented.
是的，他们选了。那它对普韦布洛人有什么影响？现在那里的情况怎么样？是的，我问过罗珊这个问题。她说村庄的中心仍然保留着古老的土坯建筑。但村庄的中心已经搬空了很多人。它有点像一座鬼城，只有在节日或特定场合才会热闹起来。有一些房子里还住着人，但大多数人都搬到了郊区。所以它破裂了，分裂了。
But Roxanne says on the positive side, there's been a resurgence of interest in traditional Adobe building techniques and she actually teaches workshops on Adobe construction. And she really credits her mom with giving her that sense of possibility when it comes to building. When we were talking, she told me this great story about how her first major building project
但罗珊说，从积极的方面来看，人们对传统土坯建筑技术的兴趣有所复苏，她实际上还在教授土坯建筑的工作坊。她非常感谢母亲赋予了她在建筑方面的这种无限可能感。我们在交谈时，她给我讲了一个很棒的故事，关于她的第一个重大建筑项目
was this family home that she built with her mom and dad. And she was a young teenager. She was in junior high. I got to build my own bedroom. And I'm a little kid, and I got to make my own bedroom. So I built me a stairway up to a bed that had a neat pattern that went up around it and the stairs were goofy, but they worked, but I could make my own room. I'm so grateful that they gave me the knowing that you can.
就是她和爸爸妈妈一起建造的这个家庭住宅。当时她还是个小青少年的年纪。她读初中。我能自己造我的卧室。我还是个小孩子，我能自己弄一间卧室。所以我给自己搭了一条通往床的楼梯，床周围有一个很别致的图案，楼梯虽然有点笨拙，但它们能用，而且我自己做出了我的房间。我非常感激他们让我懂得了“你可以做到”这一点。
And so, you know, it's kind of that sense of possibility that she got from her mom. You know, that's what she wants to give other people in the Pueblo. There's this very long tradition of building there, and that, you know, they can do this. Wow, but it's so cool. Well, thanks so much, Delaney. I really appreciate you bringing this little extra part of the story to us. Yeah, yeah. Thank you. Yeah, yeah, thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our senior producer Delaney Hall, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald and Katie Mingle, mixed by Bryson Barnes, fact-checking by Frances Card Jr. Music by Sean Riel.
所以，你知道的，正是她从母亲那里得到的这种无限可能感。你知道的，这也是她想带给普韦布洛其他人的东西。那里有着非常悠久的建筑传统，而且，你知道的，他们能够做到这一点。哇，这太酷了。好的，非常感谢你，德兰妮。非常感谢你给我们带来这个故事的额外部分。不客气，不客气。谢谢。是的，谢谢。《99%隐形》本周由我们的资深制作人德兰妮·霍尔制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和凯蒂·明格尔编辑，布赖森·巴恩斯混音，弗朗西斯·卡德尔·小负责事实核查。音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。
Crucoste is the digital director of the rest of the team, is Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Abby Medon, Chris Barube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Daniel Wuerweth, Rose Simpson, and the Archives of American Art at the Smithsonian Institution for the John Gaul meme oral history interview, which was conducted on December 3rd, 1964.
克鲁科斯特是其余团队的数字总监，成员包括乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、艾比·梅登、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢丹尼尔·韦尔韦斯、罗斯·查普斯，以及史密森尼学会美国艺术档案馆提供的约翰·高尔·米姆口述历史访谈，该访谈于1964年12月3日进行。
Thanks also to Audra Belmore, the curator of the John Gaul meme archives of Southwestern architecture at UNM. Finally, special thanks to the historic division's partners in the study they conducted. They include New Mexico Health Equity Partnership, Historian and Preservation Planner, John Murphy, Six Blooms, and little globe ink. Little globe has been conducting interviews with people in Santa Fe's historic district and helped connect us with Ray Herrera.
同时感谢奥德拉·贝尔莫尔，她是UNM西南部建筑约翰·高尔·米姆档案馆的馆长。最后，特别感谢历史部门在他们开展的研究中的合作伙伴。其中包括新墨西哥健康公平伙伴关系、历史学家兼保护规划师约翰·墨菲、六朵花以及小地球公司。小地球公司一直在对圣菲历史街区的人们进行采访，并帮助我们与雷·埃雷拉取得联系。
We are a project from 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which exists in various corners of North America, but in its heart will always be in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a member of RadioOTOPIA from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Discover, listen and support them all at radiotopia.fm.
我们是来自旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在无线电街区制作，该街区存在于北美洲的各个角落，但其核心永远在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的RadioTOPIA成员，这是一个汇集了播客界最棒、最具创新性节目的联盟。欢迎在 radiotopia.fm 上发现、收听和支持他们所有人。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You like pictures of buildings made of mud? Well, I certainly do. me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram and ready to. You like pictures of buildings made of mud? Well, I certainly do. And we got a bunch of them at 99PI.org. Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在脸书上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你喜欢泥土造的建筑的照片吗？嗯，我当然喜欢。@我 Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你喜欢泥土造的建筑的照片吗？嗯，我当然喜欢。我们在 99PI.org 上收集了一大堆这样的照片。来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。